point de l'émission j'accueille hervé
bourges
on sera président sa main et bouteilles
heureux de vous moi mais moi aussi
savoir quand même que j'ai commencé la
télé il ya vingt ans et mon premier
patron c'est hervé bourges avec marie
france brière pascal josèphe catherine
barma mais de la possibilité de
commencer à la télé voyez le résultat
bravo on jouait le chat [ __ ] sur le
service public c'est bien la peine de
faire faire de la télé j'ai croisé
j'étais avec mon chien je faisais piece
yellow le meilleur je soutenais assez
marrant je croise en plus souvent est
souvent devenue espace camille bien tout
peut peut-être dire où ces deux rives
côté de la rue montmailler on a beaucoup
de sympathie l'un pour l'autre
à chaque fois on s'arrête invite à ses
spectacles pour moi décousu voilà
etienne daho bon parlons pas on se
connaît pas vous avez ces listes oui
bien sûr
sortir ce soir etienne daho bon ça va ça
l'entrée bien lyonnais qu'il me manque
ce soir c'est ma fille et ma fille je
vais vous dire pourquoi
oui parce que vous souvenez au départ
dans quand vous êtes rentré à la
télévision avec moi et qu'il y avait des
tas de gens qui disaient des tas de
choses et puis dit se plaignaient de
baffie etc
je regarde moi chaque semaine votre
émission j'apprécie et puis je trouve
que ba fils a pris sacrément de
l'épaisseur il aimait ça oui beaucoup
alors vous l'embrasserai pour - laval
entier présents à leur merci pour lui un
jour un jour mais convoqué chez hervé
bourges à l'époque président de france
télévisions avec d'affilée un matin et
puis on arrive on se fait engueuler on
avait fait une connerie encore je sais
pas quoi et on arrive dans le bureau
tous les deux face à hervé bourges et et
et le président bush et ben fille lui
fait vous avez fait un vote au président
s'imagine désespéré déjà on va se faire
virer faca et vous avez été super cool
vous êtes jeune fille mais c'est vrai
c'est pas vrai bon je réponds
excusez-moi président au prix où il
quitta l'appareil attend c'est énorme je
vous jure c'est énorme c'est ma fille
qui me dira non parler le lot il me dit
si fait un retour je te le pas ça c'est
trop fort
hindi bbc sarko c'est marc attend vient
en parle au nom joue pas ça c'est non
allô oui vous allez bien j'ai dit que
vous nous manquez beaucoup ce soir parce
que je voulais dire beaucoup de bien de
vous voyez non mais c'est vrai mais vous
êtes gentil aussi
quant aux routes autour qu'est ce que
vous voulez ça m'a passé un c'est
dommage mais reposez vous bien je vois
que vous faites comme tout le monde
c'est la semaine de vacances vous
l'apprenez en fait pas qu'il la prend sa
semaine de vacances ces connards oui
assez sévère tt ah bon c'est pas mal non
c'est bien que c'était non oui bon mais
très bien alors jours passent thierry
alors je sais pas si je vais danser le
téléphone non il faut pas je suis
attentive hier c'est que j'aime bien
voir ce serait le téléphone la
production s'en foutrait mais comme
c'est bien à l'eau
ils vivent les nouvion mais c'est lui
qui a des renvois c'est bien en même
temps c'est la même par téléphone c'est
moins cher j'espère c'est beaucoup moins
cher
écoute bien
j'en ai plus l arrière mais toujours
ensemble ça arrive ça va durer jusque là
jusqu'à 4 bon enfin donc vous publié
aujourd'hui un essai un nouvel essai
parce que c'est pas le premier
c'est chez ram c'est ça s'appelle sur la
télé mes quatre vérités
alors vous parlez de la télévision
aujourd'hui vous vous réjouissez de
l'ouverture de la télévision au secteur
privé effectivement il ya une une
vingtaine d'années bon ben avouez quand
même que tf1 la chaîne que vous
présidiez à l'époque est loin du mieux
disant culturel que bouygues nous avait
promis quand il a racheté la chaîne
quand même là pas promis à moi il l'a
promis à l'organisme de régulation qui à
l'époque cnc qui lui a attribué la
chaîne et c'est vrai qu'il ya eu un
cahier des charges extraordinaires il
devait faire beaucoup de deux programmes
culturels et cetera je dirais que c'est
un petit peu un mensonge tout ça parce
que vous n'allez pas demander à une
chaîne commerciale de prendre des
engagements sur des programmes que
malheureusement je dis bien
malheureusement peu de gens regardent un
le mieux disant culturel a été emporté
par la logique commerciale
donc on nous a menti à l'époque sûrement
sur non mais c'est pas ceux qui ont
acheté qui ont menti ils ont joué je
sais pas le faire
c'est ce qu'ils ont vendu c'est à dire
les politiques hélas cette chaîne elle
était financée tf1 parle par les impôts
des français quoi puis oui c'était une
chaîne de tous les sens et c'est la
première fois au monde qu on a privatisé
une chaîne publique
les trois milliards de francs de
l'époque kaka données bouygues
ils ont pas été rendu aux français donc
c'est quelque chose qui avait été
financé par les français
oui sur la redevance sur la redevance
mais on leur a jamais rendu le pognon
non ils venaient quoi ce pognon les 3
milliards ils sont devenus voit bien
mois faut que les français demandent ça
à l'état - posez la question à moins qu
en syrie
wick de nos 3 milliards de francs
nouveau mais ces trois milliards on n'a
jamais rendu aux gens qui avaient payé
leur donne donc une arnaque d'accord
président auchan c'est rien c'est du
passé
ouais je sais pas du tout au courant de
cette histoire
au départ ils ont vendu au départ c'est
mieux disant culturel et puis maintenant
disponible oui oui mais mais mais ceci
étant là dessus c'est facile de de faire
des jeux de mots et de dire c'est
scandaleux
monsieur le lait uht cette phrase etc
moi je dis c'est dans la logique
commerciale une chaîne commerciale et
l'air pour faire de l'argent et s'il
faisait pas d'argent avec des
actionnaires ficherait en l'air le lin
chi qui la dirige donc pourquoi lui
faire ce reproche le reproche qu'on peut
faire c'est à ceux qui ont vendu tf1 qui
en ont qu'ils ont privatisé
est ce que vous croyez que france 2 va
être privatisée président que non ce
chez vous savez ça ça fait partie encore
des loups qui courent de toujours dans
le monde des convois dans le monde de
l'audiovisuel des convois quelque chose
qui existe que qui à la mondialisation
qui qui la mine tout on se dit dans le
domaine de la télévision
il ya peut-être trop de chaînes de
service public alors qu'en fait y en a
pas beaucoup et il faut privatiser
franche de d'autant plus que certains
disent tf1 à une telle puissance
aujourd'hui qu'il faudrait que cette
pièce donc sur coise moins importante et
qui est un grand concurrent et pour être
franche de mais ceci étant on des frais
quelque chose qui existe et qui est
arrivé à un point d'équilibré vous savez
en ce moment entre les chaînes
commerciales sur tf1 et m6 et le service
public france 2 france 3 france 5
bientôt france 4 avec le numérique bien
ça s'équilibre au niveau de l audience
et en europe c'est à peu près ce qui
existe et c'est une bonne chose parce
que si on supprimait encore une chaîne
du service public
ben je crois qu on enlèverait aux
français une partie de ce qui fait quand
même la possibilité d'avoir d'autres
programmes que ce qu'on voit
habituellement sur les chaînes
commerciales dans le domaine de la télé
réalité par exemple on aime on n'aime
pas la télé réalité moi je suis pas
content s'il ya des gens qui aiment ça
pourquoi les chaînes commerciales n'en
ferai pas m'enfin
si le service public se laisser aller à
ça je crois que ce serait assez grave
alors vous raconter tout ça dans votre
bouquin seulement ça a pas seulement ça
nous allons vous parler aussi de canal
quand vous avez été obligé d'intervenir
en tant que patron du csa
quand il y avait cette fusion canal + 2
6 grammes
vous racontez ça et alors vous passez
une volée de bois vert à frédéric
beigbeder le pot pour son émission qu'il
a fait sur canal la l'hyper chaud oui
parce qu'elles étaient lamentables
nous avec bd on peut aimer son talent
par ailleurs l'écrivain puisqu'il a fait
un livre à succès il a fait l'aller va
cliquer yeux aujourd'hui il est dans une
maison d'édition puis qu'il a fait de la
télévision oui c'est un garçon qui a
beaucoup de talent mais mais après le
canal + qui sombre et un à cause de
monsieur messier la seule chose qu'il
ait réussi à faire c'est une émission
lamentable un bon moi je le dis à vous
mais pas renié pas non plus moi c'est
pas que je vous épargne pas je dis que
je vous aime beaucoup et communiqué que
vous avez beaucoup de talent un savez je
me souviens d'une et thouars où on a
pris tous les risques
à 10 ans c'est vrai j'avais j'avais
décelé en vous je le dis ici beaucoup de
talent et je dirait quelqu'un qui au
delà de
quelquefois des dérapages est un type
qui pensent qu'à une culture et à
utiliser du bien de vous je suis obligée
de revenir sur saulx cabanis sur voilà
sur cabanis sur une barque pendant vos
émissions vous poser la question sur le
kabbani alors sur le cabanis vous allume
pas je vous aime pas je dis que bien des
gens qui fument
c'est leur affaire un mois je bois de
temps en temps une coupe de champagne
c'est aussi un poison
je fume de temps en temps un cigare il
paraît que c'est du poison
mais c'est mon affaire mais j'en fait
pas la promotion 1 et je trouve que
chrétiens comme vous n'a pas faire la
promotion d'un produit qui qui tue les
gens quand même je dis qu'un type comme
vous aussi intelligent vous êtes aussi
que nivet vous êtes vous pourriez vous
vous en dispenser une différence quand
même entre un petit pétard le soir avec
des potes
bien sûr et puis les gones qui
s'envoient de l'as cannes le matin avant
de partir les oui parce que les
seringues célèbre qui enrichit en thc si
vous fumez salle matin à l'école vous
êtes défoncer à mort c'est vrai dire aux
jeunes de pergame voilà pas touche à ce
nom bien sûr faux pas qui rangeait plus
un génie c'est le mec qui fait quand et
trotter tropicaux donc respecte
alors voilà effectivement on parlait de
la censure ou parler de la mission
culturelle de la télé vous par
l'élection de marc tessier puisque vous
étiez le patron du csa les bucks qui
savent être le nouveau président de
france télévisions a écouté c'est marc
tessier moi je suis pour la continuité
maintenant je n'ai pas d'avis à donner
pour une raison très simple que je ne
suis pas décideur mais je constate que
dans la télévision privée il ya des
présidents qui sont là depuis qu'ils
sont à la tête de la chaîne c'est-à-dire
depuis 1987 et que dans le service
public c'est la tournante
il se trouve que
on a fait une loi qui permet d'avoir un
mandat maintenant de cinq ans il est bon
que des présidents qui n'ont pas
démérité puis-je continuer donc c est ça
qui va décider de toute façon oui c'est
ça qui va décider
on va faire une interview csa